What's it like to trade crypto on Kraken? Let's say I'm in a state-of-the-art gym surrounded by powerful-looking machines. Do I head straight for the squat rack? I could, but this gym has options, like trainers, fitness pros, fodders to back me up. That's crypto on Kraken, powerful crypto tools backed by 24-7 support and multi-layered security. Go to kraken.com and see what crypto can be. Not investment advice. Crypto trading involves risk of loss. See kraken.com slash legal slash ca dash pru dash disclaimer for info on Kraken's undertaking to register in Canada. What does possible sound like for your business?
在 Kraken 上交易加密货币是什么体验？假设我在一个顶尖的健身房里，周围都是看起来力量感十足的器械。我是该直奔深蹲架吗？我当然可以，但这家健身房还有很多选择，比如教练、健身专家、随时支持我的后盾。这就是 Kraken 上的加密货币，强大的加密工具背后有 7x24 小时全天候支持和多层安全性。访问 kraken.com，探索加密货币的无限可能。非投资建议。加密货币交易存在亏损风险。有关 Kraken 在加拿大注册承诺的信息，请访问 kraken.com slash legal slash ca dash pru dash disclaimer。对于您的企业而言，无限可能意味着什么？
It's more cash on hand to grow with up to 55 interest-free days. Redefine possible with Business Platinum. That's the powerful backing of American Express. Terms and conditions apply. Visit amex.ca slash business platinum. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
这是更多的可用现金，助您实现业务增长，最高可享 55 天免息期。用 Business Platinum 重新定义无限可能。这是美国运通的强大后盾。适用条款与条件。请访问 amex.ca slash business platinum。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. ["The Office Theme"] Hello.
我们是好朋友。现在，我们专门为你带来了终极办公室重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。“《办公室》主题曲”你好。
Hi. We're talking about Living the Dream Part 2. It's a two-parter. Wasn't supposed to be a two-parter, became a two-parter. Mm-hmm. This is season 9, episode 23, written by Nikki Schwartz Wright and directed by Jeffrey Blitz. Do you want a little summary catch up?
嗨。我们正在聊《活出梦想》第 2 部分。这是一集上下两集的内容。本来不该是两集的，结果分成了两集。嗯哼。这是第九季第二十三集，由妮基·施瓦茨·怀特编剧，杰弗里·布利茨执导。你想听听简短的剧情回顾吗？
I think we need a recap because even in the episode when it aired, there was a previously on The Office. Yes, well that's how it is now. It originally aired altogether, but now they, for syndication or what do you call it? The DVD and Apple. It's one episode on the DVD. No kidding.
我觉得我们需要回顾一下，因为即使在这集首播时，也有过《办公室》的前情提要。对，现在的剧集就是这样。它原本是一起播出的，但现在为了联合播出或者怎么说呢？DVD 和 Apple。在 DVD 上它是一集。真的吗？
Yep. But it's two episodes on Apple. It is. We got to the bottom of that. We're solving cases already today. Oh man. Oh, I'm feeling good. Well.
是的。但在 Apple 上它是两集。确实是。我们今天已经查清这一点了。我们今天已经在破案了。天哪。哦，我感觉很好。好吧。
All right. Let me tell you what's gonna happen this week. Dwight will be appointed manager. Yes. And he's gonna offer Jim a new role in the company as well. Now, in the previous episode, Andy decided to quit to pursue his dreams. Well, now he's gonna decide to stay, but be a salesman.
好了。让我来告诉你们这周会发生什么。德怀特将被任命为经理。是的。而且他还要给吉姆在公司安排一个新角色。在前一集中，安迪决定辞职去追求他的梦想。现在，他决定留下来，但要当一名销售员。
He's doing a little bit of snip, snap, snip, snap. He is, it's true. Because at the end, he's gonna change his mind again. Big time. Finally, Angela is gonna be evicted from her apartment and Jim is gonna receive some very good but complicated news about athlete. But before we get into all that, Angela,
他这叫反复无定，变来变去。确实如此，真的是这样。因为到最后，他又要改变主意了。太夸张了。最后，安吉拉将被驱逐出她的公寓，而吉姆将收到关于阿瑟的非常棒但又有些复杂的消息。但在我们深入探讨这些之前，安吉拉，
I believe you have a share. I do, and I'm really excited about it. I'm excited. I've been waiting for weeks for you to be able to share this. Okay. Well, let me start by asking you and Sam and Cassie this question. Have you ever written a family Christmas letter or received one? Well, I receive many every year and I love them. I really like the little update letter that people send with all the details.
我相信你有一件想分享的事。是的，我真的超级兴奋。我很兴奋。我等了好几个星期，就为了能把这件事分享出来。好吧。那我就先问你、萨姆和卡西一个问题。你们写过或者收到过家庭圣诞信吗？我每年都会收到很多，而且我很喜欢。我真的很喜欢人们随信附上带有各种细节的小近况信。
I love them, I live for them. I'm on a few of like my mom's friends' Christmas card list and I get the letter from some of these ladies that I grew up knowing. I hang on every word. Same. Now, have I written one? I wrote one one year and I found it so stressful
我很喜欢它们，我的生活离不开它们。我在我妈妈的一些朋友的圣诞卡名单上，我会收到一些我从小就认识的女士们写来的信。我对她们的每个字都铭记于心。我也是。那么，我写过吗？我有一年写过一封，我觉得压力太大了，
I never did it again. Really? Yes. I couldn't, it was just, I was like, what do I include? What do I not include? It is, it's stressful, right? It's very stressful. Sam, Cassie?
就再也没写过了。真的吗？是的。我做不到，我当时就在想，我该写进去什么？不该写进去什么？真的很让人压力山大，对吧？压力非常大。萨姆，卡西？
I don't get letters, but I always get pictures of my friends with their pets. And I love those. I've received many. I've written zero. Okay. All right. Well, I love a Christmas letter.
我不怎么收信，但我总是收到朋友们和他们宠物的照片。我超喜欢那些。我收到过很多。我一封都没写过。好吧。好吧。我超爱圣诞信的。
And if you saw my post last week on Instagram, you know I was super excited about this opportunity that came my way. I am the lead. The lead, the lead, the lead. In a new Hallmark Christmas movie. I am so excited about this. It is such a sweet movie. It's funny, it's heartfelt.
如果你看了我上周在 Instagram 上的发帖，你就会知道我对这个找上门来的机会感到超级兴奋。我是主角。主角，主角，主角。在一部全新的 Hallmark 圣诞电影里。我太激动了。这是一部非常温馨的电影。它很有趣，也很走心。
I can't wait for you guys to see it. My mom is over the moon. Oh, my mom is over the moon. Well, Ange, I know this has been a bucket list item of yours and when this came along, I feel like we just both squealed with excitement and I'm so glad that it got to happen. I have to say two big thank yous.
我迫不及待想让你们看到了。我妈妈高兴坏了。哦，我妈妈高兴极了。安吉，我知道这一直是你的愿望清单之一，当这个机会出现时，我觉得我们俩都兴奋得尖叫起来，我真的很高兴它能变成现实。我必须表达两声巨大的感谢。
One is to my husband Josh, who held down the fort at home so I could go do this. Cause you were gone, maybe the longest. You've had to be gone for a role. It's the longest we've ever been apart in our marriage. It was three weeks. Which feels like a long time. It does.
首先要感谢我的丈夫乔什，他在家里稳住大局，我才能去完成这件事。因为你离开的时间，可能是我有史以来最长的一次。你为了一个角色不得不离开。这是我们婚姻中分开最长的一次。足足有三个星期。感觉像是好长一段时间。确实如此。
When you're never apart. And then also I really want to thank you and Cassie and Sam for the way you came together and helped me get through this time. I took my microphone with me. I was recording ads at night when I rapped. I was loopy. But you guys all really came through for me. So thank you.
当你从来没有分开过的时候。然后我也真的很想感谢你、卡西和萨姆，感谢你们齐心协力帮我度过了这段时间。我把麦克风带在身边了。我收工后在晚上录制广告。我当时神志不清的。但你们真的都全力支持了我。所以谢谢你们。
Well, we can't wait to see it. Will you tell us what it's about? I will give you a little summary. I'm going to do a summary, Jenna. It's called Confessions of a Christmas Letter. And the premise is that this little town where my character lives has an annual Christmas writing letter contest. And the winner gets proudly displayed on the post office wall along with a picture of the family. So your letter's in a frame, your family picture's in a frame, and it is a big, big deal in this small town.
我们等不及要看了。你能给我们讲讲讲的是什么吗？我会给你们做个简短的总结。我来做个总结，珍娜。这部电影叫《圣诞信的忏悔》。剧情设定是，我这个角色所居住的小镇有一个年度圣诞写信比赛。获胜者的信会被自豪地展示在邮局的墙上，旁边还有一张全家福照片。所以你的信被装裱起来了，你的全家福也被装裱起来了，这在这个小镇上可是一件天大的事。
And my character is horrible at writing Christmas letters. And her next door neighbor who's like the town snarky lady wins every year, you know? Yeah. So my character decides this year she's going to hire a novelist to write her letter for her. That's very sneaky. Very sneaky and hijinks ensue. It's really fun and it's just a really sweet, fun movie and I hope you guys all like it. I already love it. And there's a really fun cameo, Jenna Knows This, it's by Brian Baumgartner.
而我这个角色偏偏特别不擅长写圣诞信。她隔壁的邻居，也就是镇上那个刻薄的女人，每年都赢得比赛，你知道的？是的。所以我的角色决定今年她要雇一个小说家来帮她写信。这太狡猾了。非常狡猾，并且状况百出。这真的很有趣，而且是一部非常温馨、搞笑的电影，我希望你们都会喜欢。我已经开始喜欢了。里面还有一个非常有趣的客串，珍娜知道这个，是布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳。
We had such a fun time working together again. So cool. I know. And hey, I just wanna throw this out there. Listen, everyone at Hallmark was so fantastic. I had such a blast. I kinda feel like there's a mom detective Christmas caper out there, lady.
我们再次合作得非常开心。太酷了。我知道。嘿，我想顺便提一下。听着，Hallmark 的每个人都太棒了。我玩得太开心了。我觉得外面还有一部妈妈侦探圣诞惊悚片在等着我们呢，女士。
Stop it. You and I could be the mom detective Christmas Hallmark movie. Let me say one thing to that. Y-E-S exclamation point. Okay? For sure. Do you know when your Christmas movie is coming out yet? Yes, I do. It's going to premiere on Sunday, November 17th, and it's going to re-air throughout December. Yay, I love it. We have to have a viewing party.
别说了。你和我可以拍一部妈妈侦探圣诞 Hallmark 电影。对此我只想说一句话。Y-E-S，后面加个感叹号。好吗？绝对的。你知道你的圣诞电影什么时候上映吗？是的，我知道。它将于 11 月 17 日星期日首播，并在整个 12 月期间重播。耶，我太喜欢了。我们必须办个观影派对。
Oh, I really want to. Yes. Anyway, yay, that's my big share. Yay, I love it. Well, listen, why don't we take a break, and then when we come back, we'll break down, live in the the dream part duh, part duh. Here we go.
哦，我真的很想。是的。不管怎样，耶，这就是我要分享的大事。耶，我太喜欢了。好了，听着，我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来后，我们就来剖析一下，《活出梦想》第...呃...第...呃部分。我们开始吧。
["Live in the Dream Part Duh"] Summers here and you can now get almost anything you need for your sunny days delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? Well, you can't get a well-groomed lawn delivered, but you can get a chicken Parmesan delivered. A cabana, that's a no, but a banana, that's a yes. A nice tan, sorry, nope, but a box fan, happily yes. The The only way we go home is together. From New Season now streaming exclusively on Paramount+. I'm Jean Marie Laskus.
“《活出梦想》第...呃部分”夏天到了，现在你可以通过 Uber Eats 配送买到几乎所有阳光灿烂的日子里需要的东西。我们说的“几乎”是什么意思？嗯，你没法让修剪得整整齐齐的草坪送货上门，但你可以点一份帕尔马鸡肉送到家。海滩小屋？不行，但香蕉？可以。想晒成健康的古铜色？抱歉，不行，但箱式风扇？绝对没问题。我们回家的唯一方式就是在一起。全新一季现正于 Paramount+ 独家热播。我是琼·玛丽·拉斯库斯。
I'm a journalist. I spent my career helping Americans understand the lives of other Americans. Coal miners, gun shop clerks, staffers in the White House mailroom. In my new podcast, Cement City, I tell the story of an entire town. A dying town that you have absolutely no reason to care about. But trust me, you will. Listen to and follow Cement City, an Odyssey Original Podcast in partnership with Cement City Productions. Available now for free on the Odyssey app and wherever you get your podcasts.
我是一名记者。我职业生涯的大部分时间都在帮助美国人了解其他美国人的生活。煤矿工人、枪械店店员、白宫收发室的工作人员。在我的新播客《水泥城》中，我讲述了一个小镇的故事。一个你完全没有理由去关心的垂死小镇。但相信我，你会关心的。收听并关注《水泥城》，这是 Odyssey 原创播客，由水泥城制作公司联合呈现。现已在 Odyssey 应用程序以及各大播客平台免费上线。
["The Odyssey"] ["The Odyssey"] All right, we are back and this episode is gonna pick up literally where last week left off. Dwight is entering the conference room and David Wallace has something to say. Rain played this so well, the emotion on Dwight's face. It was this combination of being teary. I was like teary and laughing.
“《奥德赛》”“《奥德赛》”好的，我们回来了，这一集将直接从上周结束的地方开始。德怀特走进了会议室，大卫·华莱士有话要说。雷恩把这一幕演得太好了，德怀特脸上的表情。那是一种含泪的复合情绪。我当时觉得又含泪又想笑。
Yep, I have watched ahead to AARM part one and two. You and Rain, your combination of emotion and comedy in these episodes leading to the finale is so amazing. I mean, I'm going to get to yours later in this breakdown, but so good, Angela. Oh my God. Thanks, lady. Well, David says, I would like you to be manager.
是的，我已经超前看过了 AARM 上集和下集。你和雷恩在这些通往大结局的剧集中将情感和喜剧完美结合，真是太惊艳了。我的意思是，我等会儿在这个解析中会谈到你的部分，真的太棒了，安吉拉。天哪。谢谢你，女士。好吧，大卫说，我想让你担任经理。
Dwight already has a business card ready. I know. You can't believe it. He had one ready just in case Michael or Andy ever got killed in a traffic accident and there was a trade show on the exact same day. He's a planner. He sure is.
德怀特已经准备好了一张名片。我知道。你简直不敢相信。他提前准备好了一张，以防迈克尔或安迪在车祸中丧生，而同一天正好有一个贸易展。他是个有远见的人。他确实是。
Listen, we got a fan question from Sammy B in Barrington, New Hampshire who said, at what point was it decided that Dwight would be manager? It's the perfect culmination of his storyline. It really is. Well, basically, Sammy, as soon as they knew that the spin-off wasn't happening, they knew that Dwight needed to end this series as manager of Dunder Mifflin. I actually reached out to Greg, and he said that the discussions over how to end the show focused a lot on what each character deserved.
听着，我们收到了来自新罕布什尔州巴灵顿的萨米·B 的粉丝提问，他问：是在哪个时间点决定让德怀特成为经理的？这是对他故事线的完美总结。确实如此。嗯，基本上，萨米，一旦他们知道衍生剧不会拍了，他们就知道德怀特需要以邓德米夫林的经理身份来结束这个系列。我实际上联系了格列布，他说关于如何结束这部剧的讨论，很大程度上集中在每个角色应得的结局上。
Like, how could we make everyone's, maybe make their wildest dreams come true, but also what do they deserve to get from this journey? And Greg said that Dwight was a man with very clear passions. It was not hard to figure out what would make him happy. And he said most character arcs were decided about a quarter of the way through season nine
比如，我们如何能让每个人的梦想成真，或者说，从这段旅程中，他们应该得到什么回报？格列布说，德怀特是一个有着非常明确热情的人。弄清楚什么能让他开心并不难。他说，大多数角色的成长弧线大约在第九季进行到四分之一的时候就已经决定了，
so that they could slowly write toward all of them. Well, I have to tell you guys, while I was in Canada filming this movie, Greg and I were texting and we realized we were both in Vancouver on the same day. And we both realized this on our last day there. So we were able to meet and have lunch. It was so great.
这样他们就可以朝着这些方向慢慢编写剧本了。好吧，我得告诉你们，当我在加拿大拍这部电影时，格列布和我一直在发短信，我们突然发现我们俩在同一天都在温哥华。而且我们都是在我们在那里的最后一天才发现这一点的。所以我们得以见面并共进午餐。真是太棒了。
We hung out for two hours. We laughed, we talked about the show. It was so great. We hung out for two hours. We laughed. We talked about the show. He is so happy for Office Ladies and for what we've done in the rewatch, Jenna. And I hope we get to have him on again because he's just rooting for us. And he's like, Ange, where are you in season nine? Tell me everything. I love him.
我们在一起闲逛了两个小时。我们欢笑，我们谈论这部剧。真是太棒了。我们在一起闲逛了两个小时。我们欢笑，我们谈论这部剧。他为“办公室女士”以及我们在重温节目中所做的一切感到非常高兴，珍娜。我希望我们能再次邀请他上节目，因为他一直在为我们加油打气。他会问，安吉，你看到第九季哪儿了？快告诉我一切。我太喜欢他了。
I know. You know, he told me that when they start filming this spin-off, that we can come to the set and get a behind-the-scenes, I guess, view of all the goings on. And I can't wait. And we get to tell you guys about it. Yeah. Well, speaking of behind-the-scenes, how do you like that segue? Angela's doing something behind-the-scenes under her desk.
我知道。你知道的，他告诉我，等他们开始拍摄这个衍生剧时，我们可以去片场，参观一下幕后制作，了解一下所有的进展。我简直等不及了。而且我们可以把这些讲给你们听。是的。说到幕后，你觉得这个过渡怎么样？安吉拉在她的办公桌底下搞点幕后小动作。
She is pouring, is it vodka? It's a clear alcohol. And to her, big 7-Eleven Super Gulp is what it looks like. She's basically become Meredith. Yes! She's got a lot going on, and she's not handling it very well. Meanwhile, Pam goes back to the Annex to visit Jim.
她在倒，是伏特加吗？是一种透明的酒精饮料。对她来说，这看起来就像是 7-Eleven 的特大杯饮料。她基本上变成梅雷迪思了。是的！她最近事挺多，而且处理得不太好。与此同时，帕姆回到附楼去看望吉姆。
She has a question for him, but she can't remember what it is. Oh, this is such like back to Jim Annex to visit Jim. She has a question for him, but she can't remember what it is. Oh, this is such like back to Jim and Pam flirty days. I love that they rack focus to Toby. He's in agony. Yes. It was so fun to finally get to play Happy Jim Pam again. Yeah, I bet.
她有个问题想问他，但她想不起来是什么了。哦，这简直就像是回到了吉姆附楼去看望吉姆。她有个问题想问他，但她想不起来是什么了。哦，这简直就像是回到了吉姆和帕姆打情骂俏的日子。我喜欢他们把焦点迅速切换到托比身上。他痛苦万分。是的。终于又能演到快乐的吉姆和帕姆了，真的好开心。是的，我敢说。
And now when I'm rewatching it and I'm seeing it, I see how very long it has been. Andy is now going to address the whole bullpen. He announces he's decided to stay at Dunder Mifflin and transition to sales. Nellie thinks this could be his best role yet. Everyone's very supportive of this idea. Yeah. I need you all though to go to four minutes and 26 seconds. What will I see? Well, I have a Dundee to four minutes and 26 seconds. What will I see? Well, I have a Dundee to give out in this scene. What is it?
现在当我重新观看并看到这一幕时，我才发现时间已经过去这么久了。安迪现在要对全体大办公室的人讲话了。他宣布他决定留在邓德米夫林并转做销售。内莉认为这可能是他最适合的角色。大家都非常支持这个想法。是的。不过我需要你们把进度条拉到 4 分钟 26 秒。我会看到什么？嗯，在这个场景里我要颁发一个邓迪奖。是什么奖？
It's the hair-ific Dundee for most beautiful hair in the office and it goes to Nellie. Yes, I meant to mention this last week. There was that scene of her and Kevin in Andy's office and her hair is so voluminous. It is like what a blowout. What happened? I said this is like Victoria's Secrets model hair. You know when they stand in front of the fan? Yes. Yes. I looked in the script to see if there was a deleted storyline that pointed to why her hair is so terrific. It is phenomenal hair day for Nellie. Anyway, she gets a dundee for hairrific.
这是“发型惊艳奖”，颁给办公室里最美头发的人，得主是内莉。是的，我上周就想提这个。有她和凯文在安迪办公室的那场戏，她的头发太蓬松了。那是什么样的吹风造型啊。怎么回事？我说这简直就像维多利亚的秘密模特的发色。你知道他们站在风扇前面的时候吗？是的。是的。我在剧本里找过，看看有没有删掉的剧情解释为什么她的头发这么棒。内莉今天的发型简直无敌了。不管怎样，她因为发型惊艳而获得了一个邓迪奖。
Hello, did you see what I did there? I love it. Ah, I love a hair pun. Well should we go back to the annex? There's some cutie pie business happening right there. There is. Pete is showing Erin a new way to use the stapler. I didn't know this.
喂，你们看出我刚才的梗了吗？我太喜欢了。啊，我太喜欢谐音梗了。我们该回附楼了吗？那里正在上演一些可爱的小互动。确实如此。皮特正在向埃林展示使用订书机的新方法。我以前不知道这个。
Is it a real thing? Yes, but when am I using this? I've known this about the stapler all along, that you can switch the foot plate, and then instead of crimping in, it crimps out. When do I need to crimp out my staple? Is why? Would you use it for like a poster on the wall or something?
这是真的吗？对啊，但我什么时候会用到这个？我一直都知道订书机这一点，你可以更换底座，然后它就不会向内装订，而是向外装订。我什么时候需要把钉子向外装订？为什么？你会用它来把海报贴在墙上什么的吗？
No, no. I would use... I hadn't thought about it. Yeah. There's no use for it. Someone please write in and tell me the use for the reverse crimp. I would like to know. I would too. I should have done a deep dive on it.
不，不。我会用……我还没想过。是的。这根本派不上用场。谁能写信告诉我反向装订到底有什么用。我想知道。我也想知道。我本来应该好好深入研究一下的。
Should I do it right now? Hold on. I'm going to Google it. All right. I'm going to have some iced tea. Why would I... How are you going word it reverse? crimp a
我现在就要研究吗？等等。我要去 Google 一下。好吧。我要喝点冰茶。我为什么要……你怎么组织词语？反向装订
Staple it looks like it's for temporary or permanent stapling One is easier to remove Which one's easier to remove? I guess the crimped outward one is easier to remove Then creamton the crimped area of a stapler is used to bend the ends of a staple into secure shape that holds a paper together. Okay, so the plate that makes up for the crimp area can be adjusted for either temporary or permanent stapling. I mean, is any staple truly permanent? No, because there's that special little prongy thing that you can use to unstaple things. Stapling with the crimp area set for outward bent staples results in the weaker but easier
订书钉，看起来像是用于临时或永久装订。其中一种更容易移除。哪一种更容易移除？我猜向外装订的那种更容易移除。然后是订书机的装订区域，用来将订书钉的两端弯曲成牢固的形状，把纸张夹在一起。好吧，所以决定装订区域的底座可以调整为临时或永久装订。我的意思是，真的有哪种订书钉是永久的吗？没有，因为有一种特殊的小拨片，你可以用它来拆订书钉。将装订区域设置为向外弯曲订书钉进行装订，会导致钉子较弱，但更容易
to remove staple. Hmm. Well, I feel like we learned a lot and nothing all at the same time. Not satisfying at all. I feel like someone really over thought the staple, Ler, when they designed it. I'm not going to judge that person. They wanted to give you options, but they didn't know the prongy thing
移除。嗯。好吧，我觉得我们既学到了很多，又好像什么都没学到。一点也不满足。我觉得某人在设计订书钉时，真的把这个小东西琢磨得太过度了。我不想评判那个人。他们想给你提供选择，但他们不知道那个带小拨片的东西
was gonna be invented. There you go. That's what happened. I have an invention that I hope someone is working on. What is that? Is anyone working to make? What? You're so tickled. What is it? I got really fired up last night about it.
会被发明出来。原来如此。事情就是这样的。我有一个发明，希望有人正在研发。是什么？有人在研究制造吗？什么？你觉得太逗了。是什么？我昨晚对这个事情真的很火大。
It's so dumb. I really had this thought. I thought, is anyone working on this? Why are you angry about it? Is anyone working on making bags of cereal easier to open? Why? Why do it? making bags of cereal easier to open. Why? Why does every time I open the cereal bag,
这太蠢了。我真的有这种想法。我想，有人在研究这个吗？你为什么对此感到生气？有人在研究让麦片袋更容易打开吗？为什么？为什么要这样做？让麦片袋更容易打开。为什么？为什么每次我打开麦片袋，
does it look like a Wolverine came in to my cereal box and tore it open? Like, why is this so hard? Is anyone working? I said it out loud in my kitchen alone. I said, is no one working on this? The person who thought so deeply about our stapling needs, where is that person in the cereal bag design?
它看起来就像是一只狼獾闯进了我的麦片盒，把它撕得粉碎？就像，为什么这这么难？有人在工作吗？我在厨房里一个人大声说了出来。我说，难道没有人在这上面工作吗？那个对我们的订书需求深思熟虑的人，在麦片袋设计上那个人去哪了？
Right. Exactly. Exactly. I want to put, you know who I want to put? What? You know? Oh, gosh. This is so stupid.
对。没错。没错。我想把，你知道我想把谁安排上吗？什么？你知道吗？哦，天哪。这太蠢了。
You know who I want have put on the case? Who? Ah! Ah! This is ridiculous. I am so thankful for the person that got rid of the springy toilet paper holder. I'm so thankful now that you can get it just like on a hook or like a little arm that bends. I'm so thankful for that because no one in my house ever changed the toilet paper when
你知道我想让谁来处理这个案子吗？谁？啊！啊！这太荒谬了。我非常感谢那个淘汰了弹簧式卫生纸架的人。我现在真的很感谢你可以直接把它挂在钩子上，或者挂在一个能弯曲的小支架上。我太感谢这个设计了，因为我家里的任何人从来都不换卫生纸，
it was the springy thing. But now that it's an arm or a hook, we have fresh toilet paper. It's like the whole house collectively decided, I will do this thanks to this one person. So I'd like to put them on the cereal bag project. How can we? I can't even sip my tea. I'm laughing too hard. How can we honor this person?
当它还是那个弹簧装置的时候。但现在它变成了一个支架或一个钩子，我们就有新鲜的卫生纸了。就像全家人集体决定一样，多亏了这个人，我会主动换纸了。所以我想把他们安排到麦片袋的项目上去。我们怎么能？我甚至都不能喝一口茶了。我笑得太厉害了。我们怎么能向这个人致敬？
I wanted to sip my tea, but I'm laughing so hard I couldn't pucker my lips to sip my tea. Sam Cassie, can you find out who invented, please, the toilet paper roll hook? Person? If possible, so that we can honor them by name on the podcast today. Hook or the arm? You know what I'm talking about, the little arm that bends down. If you could find that out.
我想喝口茶，但我笑得太厉害了，嘴唇都抿不起来喝茶了。萨姆，卡西，你们能查到是谁发明的吗，拜托，卫生纸卷的挂钩？人？如果可能的话，这样我们今天就可以在播客里点名向他们致敬。钩子还是那个支架？你知道我在说什么，那个能向下弯曲的小支架。如果你能查到的话。
That'd be great. Okay. Okay, well little arm that bends down. If you could find that out. That'd be great. Okay. Okay, well meanwhile, in the annex. You can tell we haven't been in the room together in a while. It's true. Pam enters and she's going to sit on Jim's desk. And they're both flirty flirting with their fellas. Yeah.
那就太棒了。好吧。好吧，嗯，与此同时，在附楼里。看得出来我们已经有一段时间没有共处一室了。确实如此。帕姆进来了，她要在吉姆的桌子上坐下来。他们俩都在和各自的心上人打情骂俏。是的。
Erin with Pete and Pam with Jim. And they say maybe we should go on a little double date. Yeah. It's kind of like a double date. Let's do it for real. Yeah. Pete's like, boop-boop-a-doop-a-doop-a-doop.
埃林和皮特，帕姆和吉姆。他们说也许我们应该去来个小小的双人约会。是的。这有点像双人约会。我们来真的吧。是的。皮特说，嘟-嘟-阿-杜-阿-杜-阿-杜。
Yeah. Well, we had a fan question from Adam W. in Webster, New York, who said, when Pam sits down at Jim's desk, did they purposely make Pam and Erin look the same with their wardrobe and the way that Pam sat next to Jim? Well, I will tell you, Adam, it was scripted that I mirror the way Erin was sitting. I don't know about the wardrobe, but I have to imagine that was also intentional. But I have a question about this scene. Mm-hmm. Oh, is it about making plans with people?
是的。嗯，我们收到了来自纽约州韦伯斯特的亚当·W 的粉丝提问，他问：当帕姆坐在吉姆的桌子上时，他们是有意让帕姆和埃林的衣着打扮看起来一样，以及帕姆坐在吉姆旁边的姿态一样吗？嗯，我来告诉你，亚当，剧本里确实写了让我模仿埃林坐着的姿势。至于服装我就不知道了，但我不得不猜想这也是有意为之的。不过我对这场戏有个问题。嗯哼。哦，是关于和别人做计划的吗？
A little bit. I was in the scene. I played Pam. And I can't tell if Thursday is really bad for us or if I'm trying to get out of this idea of a double date. What did you think? Here were my thoughts. If someone sort of says, oh, we should do this sometime and you immediately throw out a date, it can be just a little scary because you're like, I like the idea of us getting together. I need a minute.
有一点。我当时就在那场戏里。我演的是帕姆。我分不清周四对我们来说真的很糟糕，还是我其实是在试图摆脱双人约会的这个想法。你是怎么想的？我的想法是这样的。如果有人顺口说，哦，我们改天应该一起聚聚，而你立刻就抛出一个确切的日期，这其实会有点吓人，因为你会觉得，我喜欢我们聚在一起的想法。我需要点时间。
OK, I need a minute. Maybe I'll look at my calendar. Don't put me on the idea of us getting together. I need a minute. I need a minute. Maybe I'll look at my calendar. Don't put me on the spot right away. I think that Erin was so quick to be like, okay, great, how's Thursday? And they're just like, well, you know. Well, and I think that when you have littles, the way Jim and Pam do, you can't be that spontaneous.
好吧，我需要一点时间。也许我会看一下我的日程表。别一上来就把我架在“我们聚聚吧”这个想法上。我需要一点时间。我需要一点时间。也许我会看一下我的日程表。别马上把我架在火上烤。我觉得埃林太快答应了，说，好吧，太棒了，周四怎么样？然后他们就觉得，嗯，你知道的。嗯，而且我觉得当你有了小孩子的时候，就像吉姆和帕姆那样，你没办法那么随性。
You can't just go out on Thursday. There's so many moving parts to making that happen. But I wasn't sure. And I checked the script to see, like, did it give me a direction, like, Pam trying to get out of it, or, you know, Jim trying to cover. But it didn't. It was just our lines. And I really don't know if we would want to go on a date with them or not.
你不能说走就走在周四去约会。要促成这件事有太多需要协调的环节了。但我当时不太确定。我查了剧本，看看里面有没有给我什么指导，比如帕姆试图推脱，或者，你知道的，吉姆试图打圆场。但并没有。那只是我们的台词。而且我真的不知道我们当时到底想不想跟他们去约会。
I couldn't decide. I was in the scene. I don't know. I don't remember what I was playing. Yeah, I really think that it wasn't you weren't trying to throw shade at them, but just the fact that you hesitated. Erin got so pissed off. She really did. I kind of loved her performance. I thought it was fantastic. Well, Dwight and David Wallace are now going to come out of the conference room. David says they have a big announcement, and Dwight says, can I please just do this one thing?
我拿不定主意。我当时就在那场戏里。我不知道。我不记得我当时是怎么演的了。对，我真的觉得你并不是想给他们难堪，而是因为你犹豫了，埃林就气炸了。她真的生气了。我挺喜欢她的表演的。我觉得太棒了。好了，德怀特和大卫·华莱士现在要从会议室出来了。大卫说他们有个重大的宣布，而德怀特说，我能只做这一件事吗？
I'll only ever ask to do it once. But then David gets a phone call, and it sort of stops the announcement. Yes. And then Dwight just sees his moment and takes it. He stands on top of his desk. He says, Dwight, Trute is manager! And everyone is so happy for him. Genuinely happy for him.
我这辈子只要求做这一次。但接着大卫接了个电话，这打断了宣布。是的。然后德怀特看准时机抓住了机会。他站到了自己的办公桌上。他说，德怀特·舒特是经理！所有人都为他感到高兴。发自内心地为他高兴。
I was surprised by Erin's reaction. It's the strongest reaction of the bullpen. I don't know if you clocked it. I didn't. She does a huge like fist pump in the air kind of thing. Okay. So I went to the script to see if this is something Ellie came up with. No, it was scripted. This is what it said. Erin jumps up at reception. She does Arsenio arm pumps and hoots as she runs to Dwight and hugs him. From accounting, Angela proudly and shyly watches. Andy also gets up from his chair giving Dwight a standing ovation.
我被埃林的反应惊到了。这是大办公室里反应最强烈的。我不知道你们有没有注意到。我没有。她狠狠地在空中挥了一下拳头。好吧。所以我去查了剧本，看看这是不是埃莉自己想出来的。不，剧本里写了。上面是这样写的：埃林在接待处跳了起来。她做着阿塞尼奥式的挥拳动作，一边欢呼一边跑向德怀特并拥抱了他。会计部的安吉拉骄傲又害羞地看着。安迪也从椅子上站起来，为德怀特起立鼓掌。
I like it. They really wanted Erin to celebrate this moment in the writer's room. Well Creed is going to jump on the desk and announce himself as manager. Yes. Crickets. Crickets. And then Jim and Pam are going to enter from the annex and find out the news. And this is great.
我喜欢。编剧室里的人是真的希望埃林庆祝这一刻。接着克里德跳上了办公桌，宣布自己才是经理。是的。一片死寂。一片死寂。然后吉姆和帕姆将从附楼走进来，知道了这个消息。这太棒了。
Immediately, Dwight is like, Clark, get out of this chair. Go back to the annex. Yeah. Jim, you get your seat back. I loved his line. He says, you're an Annex kid, you might be bullpen, we'll see. Here was my thing when I heard that, that's what we as the actors and the writers
德怀特立刻说：克拉克，从这把椅子上滚开。回附楼去。是的。吉姆，你拿回你自己的座位。我太喜欢他的台词了。他说，你是附楼的孩子，至于你能不能进大办公室，我们到时候再看。我听到这句台词时的想法是，这正是我们作为演员、编剧
and the production crew called those rooms. We called them the Annex and the bullpen. If you really worked there, would you call them the Annex and the bullpen? Did our like code names for these rooms slip into the script, do you think? I don't remember us on the show ever referencing them with this shorthand before as characters. A hundred percent, I feel like the Annex was our shooting vernacular. That's what I mean.
和制作团队对那些房间的称呼。我们把它们叫作附楼和大办公室。如果你真的在那里工作，你会叫它们附楼和大办公室吗？你觉得我们对这些房间的代号是不是不小心溜进剧本里了？我不记得我们在剧中作为角色以前用这种简写称呼过它们。百分之百，我觉得“附楼”是我们的拍摄俗语。这就是我的意思。
Yeah. Yeah. Because we would put the writers in the Annex so they didn't have to be in every scene. But if they worked there, it would just be human mean. Yeah, yeah. Because we would put the writers in the annex so they didn't have to be in every scene. But if they worked there, it would just be human resources. Yeah. I don't think we would have called it the annex if we worked there. I think that just.
对。对。因为我们会把编剧安排在附楼里，这样他们就不用出现在每一场戏里。但如果他们是在那里工作，那只会是人力资源部。对，对。因为我们会把编剧安排在附楼里，这样他们就不用出现在每一场戏里。但如果他们是在那里工作，那只会是人力资源部。是的。如果我们是在那里工作，我想我们不会叫它附楼。我觉得那只是。
Or the bullpen. Yeah, I think that just slipped in, like when Ed called me Ange in the scene. I think so too. Yeah. Well, Jim and Pam are going to happily take their places at their desks. They're going to air high five.
或者大办公室。是的，我觉得那只是不小心说漏嘴了，就像埃德在戏里叫我安吉一样。我也这么觉得。是的。好吧，吉姆和帕姆开开心心地回到了各自的座位上。他们隔空击掌。
It was scripted as an actual high five. And I remember John and I were like, oh, no, no, no, no, it's air high five. We air high five. You got to bring back hope in a frame. We do. There it is right there. There it is. Well, there's a super nice moment between Dwight and Jim. Jim is truly happy for Dwight and then Dwight is going to offer Jim the position of assistant regional manager. Yeah, but Jim says, I cannot accept. It's not a real job. However, I will proudly take the job of assistant to the regional manager. So sweet. And they shake on it and Dwight's like, idiot. You didn't like that. How you negotiate. And they shake on it and Dwight's like, idiot, you didn't like that's how you negotiate. I was in the general office ladies mailbag and I found a really fun letter from Marcy M. in Ransom Township, Pennsylvania, who said, I am sharing a recent news article from the Scranton
剧本里写的是真正的击掌。我记得我和约翰当时说，哦，不，不，不，不，这是隔空击掌。我们隔空击掌。你得把“希望在框里”拿回来。我们会的。它就在那儿。就在那儿。好吧，德怀特和吉姆之间有一个超级温馨的时刻。吉姆是真心为德怀特高兴，然后德怀特主动提出让吉姆担任助理区域经理。是的，但吉姆说，我不能接受。这不是一份真正的的工作。不过，我自豪地接受区域经理助理的职位。太甜了。然后他们握手言和，德怀特说，白痴。你根本不懂。这就是你谈判的方式。然后他们握手言和，德怀特说，白痴，你根本不懂——这就是你谈判的方式。我翻看了“办公室女士”的粉丝信箱，发现了一封来自宾夕法尼亚州兰森镇的玛西·M 的非常有趣的信，信中写道：我和你们分享一篇来自《斯克兰顿时报》的最新新闻报道。斯克兰顿学区最近雇用了两个人。他们创建了两个新职位。玛西说，当你读到他们的头衔时，我想你会明白我为什么要发这个。玛西还说，希望你能打开它。我不懂科技，不知道怎么发。玛西，我也不懂科技，但我们成功了。你把整个 HTTPS 冒号斜杠斜杠的网址都敲上去了，
Times with you. The Scranton School District recently hired two new people. They've created two new positions. And Marcy said, when you read their titles, I think you'll understand why I sent this. Marcy also said, I hope you can open it. I'm not tech savvy and I don't know how else to send it. Marcy, I'm not tech savvy either, but we did it. You typed out the HTTPS colon slash slash whole thing
然后我在浏览器里打开了它，看到了这篇文章。上面是这样写的：斯克兰顿学校董事会晋升了两位资深学区行政人员，分别担任助理总监和总监助理。哦，太棒了。这不是很惊艳吗？这太可爱了。我太喜欢了。
and I got it in my browser and I saw the article. Here is what it said. The Scranton School Board promoted two veteran district administrators to assistant superintendent and assistant to the superintendent. Oh, that's great. Isn't that amazing? That is so cute. I love that.
斯克兰顿。斯克兰顿。干得漂亮。我们要去斯克兰顿，太可爱了。我太喜欢了。斯克兰顿。斯克兰顿。干得漂亮。我们得去斯克兰顿，女士。我们真的得去。我希望当我们过渡到这个播客的下一个阶段时，会涉及更多的旅行。
Scranton. Scranton. Way to go. We got to go to Scranton so cute. I love that. Scranton. Scranton. Way to go. We gotta go to Scranton, lady. We really do. I hope that as we segue into the next phase of this podcast that it will involve more travel.
我知道。每次我们头脑风暴时，你都会提出一个你想去的地方。这就是问题所在。我们要去很多地方旅游。好吧，女士，我想我们也许应该休息一下。是的，当我们回来时，我有几件小礼物要送给你、萨姆和卡西，是从加拿大带回来的。
I know. Every time we brainstorm, you bring up a place you want to go. This is the problem. We have a lot of travel. Well, lady, I think maybe we should take a break. Yes, and when we come back, I have a few little things I wanna give you and Sam and Cassie from Canada.
哦，我最喜欢收礼物了，谢谢。一份精美的小礼物。搞起，搞起。“《纽约时报》”好的，我们回来了。安吉拉，在你拆开你的精美小礼物时，我们查到安吉拉心目中的英雄、那个发明了卫生纸卷挂钩的人是谁了吗？挂钩。
Oh, I love a gift, thank you. A nifty gifty. Let's do it, let's do it. ["The New York Times"] All right, we're back. And Angela, while you're unpacking your nifty gifties, did we find out Angela's hero, the person who invented the toilet paper roll? Hook. Hook.
我太兴奋了。所以我一直在寻找现代版本，但是发明卫生纸架的人是玛丽·帕特里夏·戴维森·肯纳。她还协助发明了女性卫生巾。爱了爱了。是的，这超酷的。我正试图弄清楚挂钩是什么时候出现的。所以也许它一开始是个挂钩，然后变得很花哨，
I'm very excited. So I'm trying to find like the modern version, but the person that invented the toilet paper holder is Mary Patrice Davidson Kenner. And she also helped invent the sanitary napkin for women. Love her. Yeah, which is super cool. I am trying to figure out when the hook came. So maybe it started off hook and then it got fancy
现在又回到了挂钩。所以她最初的设计是个挂钩？这就是我正在试图确认的，但我觉得是的。加油，玛丽。是的。当然是，因为玛丽心里有数。玛丽知道她的丈夫和孩子们永远不会用那个弹簧玩意的。而且在它的专利里，很明显是正面朝外的卫生纸。这对你很重要，萨姆，因为你之前提过这个。你把卫生纸放成卷轴朝前。前面朝下，这就是你要做的。
and now it's going back to hook. So her original design was a hook? That's what I'm trying to lock in, but think it was. Come on Mary. Yeah. Of course it was because Mary knew what was going on. Mary knew that her husband and kids were never gonna use a springy thing. And in the patent for it it's clearly the front-facing toilet paper. This is important to you Sam because you brought this up before. You put the toilet paper so the roll comes front-facing. Front down, that's what you do.
不是从后面。别对任何人这样做。我太满意了，谷歌。非常感谢。好的。哦，我的礼物，我的精美小礼物。好吧。所以我给你们每人在加拿大带了一点小礼物。
Not from the back. Don't do that to anybody. I'm so happy with that, Google. Thank you so much. All right. Oh, my gifties, my nifty gifties. Okay. So I got you guys each a little something in Canada.
卡西，上帝保佑你，因为我在最累的时候会在半夜给你发广告，而你总是那么乐于助人。所以我的酒店旁边就是 Roots 的旗舰店。你知道 Roots 这个牌子吗？太可爱了。所以卡西，我给你买了一件 T 恤。这礼物是不是最逊的？但它超级可爱。
Cassie, God bless you, because I would send you my ads at midnight when I was so tired and you were so helpful. So right by my hotel was the Roots flagship store. You know Roots, the brand? It's so cute. So Cassie, I got you a T-shirt. Is that the lamest gift? But it's so cute.
我觉得你穿一定超级可爱。然后是萨姆在机场。哦天哪。卡西，这是你的衬衫。是不是很可爱？对，很可爱。超级可爱。非常可爱。
And I thought it looked so cute on you. And then Sam at the airport. Oh boy. Cassie, this is your shirt. Isn't it cute? Yeah, it's cute. So cute. It's very cute.
好吧。我知道在播客里展示这些是视觉道具，各位。我会把它们发到快拍里的。就让我享受这一刻吧。萨姆，这个是在杂志摊上看到的。我知道这是什么。这是一本专门介绍《艾米莉在巴黎》的全杂志。谢谢。
OK. I know these are visual props on a podcast, y'all. I'll put them in stories. Just let me have this moment. Sam, this was on the magazine stand. I know what this is. It is a full magazine dedicated to Emily in Paris. Thank you.
上面说这是风格指南。哦，太好了，因为我最喜欢的就是服装。我知道。上面写着第四季的秘密、新剧照以及所有信息。加布里埃尔和艾米莉会在一起吗？谁在乎呢。还有 200 多张照片。太棒了。
It says it's the style guide. Oh, good, because that's what I love the most is the outfits. I know. And it says season four secrets, new pics, and all the info. Will Gabriel and Emily unite? Who cares? And 200 plus photos. Good.
全是艾米莉、明迪、卡米尔和西尔维最辣的造型。太棒了。谢谢。不客气。萨姆，我刚刚给你留了一段音频最辣的造型。太棒了。谢谢。不客气。萨姆，我昨天刚给你和贝克发了一条语音消息，说我在看《艾米莉在巴黎》时，是多么需要你们对第四季的实时解析。
Of Emily, Mindy, Camille, and Sylvie's hottest looks. Great. Thank you. You're welcome. Sam, I left you an audio's hottest looks. Great. Thank you. You're welcome. Sam, I left you an audio message just yesterday to you and Beck about how much I have needed your breakdowns of season four in real time while I'm watching Enemy in Paris.
它说出了我在观看时所有想说的话。我真的很感激你们。太好了。我很感激。萨姆的播客，太搞笑了。我们待会儿会放一个上滑链接。我知道我们以前讨论过，但我们真的很爱它。最后，珍娜，我在片场时，有一个叫奥利维亚的姑娘。
It is saying all the things that I want to say as I'm watching. And I really appreciate you. Good. I appreciate that. Sam's podcast, it's so funny. We're going to put another swipe up. I know we've talked about it before, but we love it. Lastly, Jenna, when I was on set, there was a gal named Olivia.
她太有才华了，我们在邮局拍其中一场戏时，她正在为一棵圣诞树制作手绘饰品。她能在木头上做定制彩绘。我会放一个指向她 Instagram 的上滑链接。我知道你喜欢自制礼物，看看这个。这个是给你的，挂在你的圣诞树上。这是一个小邮箱。哦天哪。我太喜欢了。是不是超级可爱？这真的是最可爱的玩意儿了。我知道上面写着“亲爱的”。还有一个小邮箱。我知道。她还做宠物相关的。如果你爱你的宠物，我觉得这些会是很棒的礼物。
She was so talented and she was making hand-painted ornaments for a Christmas tree in one of the scenes that we were doing at the post office. And she does custom paintings on wood. I'm going to put a swipe up to her Instagram. I know you love a homemade gift and look at this. This one's for you for your Christmas tree. It's a little mailbox. Oh my gosh. I love it. Isn't it so cute? It's truly the cutest dang thing. I know it says dear. And there's a little mailbox. I know. And she also does pets. Like if you love your pet, I think these are going to be great gifts.
我想给我妹妹买一个，她太爱她的狗狗了。安吉拉，我很高兴你给我们每个人都准备了礼物。太有你的风格了。而且一如既往，你给每个人都挑了最完美的礼物。各位，我超喜欢为别人买东西的。好吧，德怀特现在要去会计部视察了。奥斯卡、凯文和一个非常悲伤的安吉拉向他表示祝贺。我想和大家分享的是，我很感激杰弗里·布利茨能担任这一集的导演，因为
I think I want to get one for my sister who loves her dog so much. Angela, I love that you got us all gifts. It's so very you. And per usual, you got the perfect gift for each person. You guys, I love shopping for people. Well Dwight is now going to go check in over at accounting. Oscar and Kevin and a very sad Angela congratulate him. I wanted to share with you guys how thankful I was that Jeff Blitz was the director of this episode because
他太善良、太体贴了。他真的和我一起探讨如何构建安吉拉在这一集中的心路历程。所以在走到车里时——我们马上会讲到我这个角色在情感上承载了什么，以及所有这些小插曲——我只记得我和杰弗里进行了一次场边对话，讨论了我当时在那段情感旅程中的状态。与此同时，又为德怀特感到由衷的高兴，并且真正理解这对他来说是多么盛大的一天。是的，你知道的，我们有些导演，我们知道他们会全身心投入到喜剧效果中。
he's so kind and thoughtful. And he really worked with me on how to build what was going on in Angela throughout the episode. So that when I get to the car and we'll get to that what all my character is holding emotionally and all these little moments I just remember Jeff and I having a sidebar conversation about kind of where I was at in that emotional journey. While at the same time being so happy for Dwight and really understanding what a big day this was for him. Yeah, you know, we had some directors who we knew were just gonna really lean into comedy.
而其他导演，像杰弗里·布利茨，则非常喜欢深入挖掘人性细节。我觉得特别是对于这一集来说，你的角色心路历程，这真的是绝配。是的。好吧，安迪在一旁看着德怀特到处和大家握手，他将迎来一个顿悟时刻。
And then other directors like Jeff Blitz really liked to get into like the human details. And I think for this episode in particular, your character Journey, that was a really good match. Yeah. Well, Andy's watching as Dwight kind of goes around and is shaking hands with people and he's gonna have a realization.
他会有一个独白镜头，在镜头里他说，我真不敢相信我这么快就放弃了自己的梦想。这是因为他有这条退路。他不应该有退路的。我想指出的是，安迪的独白镜头，他是朝外看的。他正望向邓德米夫林之外的未来。这一集里很多角色都有这样的镜头。
He's gonna have a talking head where he says, I can't believe that I was so quick to abandon my dreams. And it's because he has this fallback. He shouldn't have a fallback. I would like to point out that Andy's talking head, he's facing out. He's looking out towards a future outside of Dunder Mifflin. And a lot of characters have that in this episode.
非常有意思。好吧，安迪要跳上他的办公桌，宣布他又改变主意了。他在追逐自己的梦想。他要跑回去把这个消息告诉托比，包括他需要消除所有留有退路的可能性的事实。是的，他需要托比炒了他，这样他就再也不能回邓德米夫林了。
Very interesting. Well, Andy's gonna jump on his desk to announce that he's changed his mind again. He is going after his dream. And he's gonna run back and tell Toby his news, including the fact that he needs to eliminate all possibility of a fallback plan. Yeah, he needs Toby to fire him, so he can't go back to Dundra Mifflin ever.
非常有趣。嗯，安迪要跳到他的桌子上宣布他再次改变主意了。他正在追求自己的梦想。他要跑回去把这个消息告诉托比，包括他需要消除所有退路的可能性。是的，他需要托比解雇他，这样他就永远不能回到邓德米夫林了。
Yeah, Toby's like, I have no reason to fire you. And so Andy's like, well, then I have no choice but to start groping you. Well first he says fire me for theft are groping wieners. Yes and so he's gonna I guess mildly grope Toby? Try to grope Toby. Yeah Toby's just like get off me Andy. I've got a little background catch. It's a whiteboard detail and it's also a shout out to our set decorators. We shot this episode the week of February 19th, but if you check out the whiteboard
是的，托比说，我没有理由解雇你。安迪就说，好吧，那我别无选择，只能开始对你动手动脚了。首先他说，因为偷窃或者对香肠上下其手而解雇我吧。是的，所以他打算，我猜，对托比进行轻微的毛手毛脚？试着对托比毛手毛脚。对，托比只是说，离我远点，安迪。我有一个小小的幕后花絮要分享。这是一个白板细节，也是向我们的布景装饰师致敬。我们拍摄这一集的周是2月19日那一周，但是如果你看看白板
above Toby's desk, it is for the month of May because this episode aired on May 2nd. So they had to track that and make sure that the whiteboard matched the month of release and not the month of filming. And in the next scene, we are about to go to accounting and you can see again that the calendar behind Angela is also for May. Very well done set decoration team. Angela is now going to get a call from her landlady. She's worried that maybe her rent check bounced. And Oscar and Kevin are listening and Angela is really getting into an argument with her landlady. I just want you to know there was no one talking to me.
在托比的桌子上方，那是五月份的，因为这一集是在5月2日播出的。所以他们必须追踪这一点，并确保白板与发布月份相符，而不是拍摄月份。在下一场戏中，我们即将去会计部，你可以再次看到安吉拉身后的日历也是五月份的。布景装饰团队做得非常棒。安吉拉现在要接她女房东的电话了。她担心自己的房租支票可能跳票了。奥斯卡和凯文在听，安吉拉真的在和她的女房东争论。我只是想让你知道，没有人跟我说话。
There was no one on the other side of the call. I just had to pretend like someone was saying things to me. Well, lady, Adam W. from Webster, New York is very impressed. Adam said, I need to point out how amazing the phone acting is here. Every time I watch this scene, I can perfectly imagine this real conversation between landlord and tenant is happening. Amazing in all caps. Thank you. I agree. And also, we got a letter from Laura M. in Hampshire, England who said, not a question, but Angela goes all southern on the
电话的那头没有任何人。我只是得假装有人在对我说些什么。好吧，女士，来自纽约韦伯斯特的亚当·W.印象非常深刻。亚当说，我需要指出这里的电话演技有多么惊人。每次我看这场戏时，我都能完美地想象房东和租客之间真实的对话正在发生。全大写字母的惊人。谢谢。我同意。而且，我们收到了来自英国汉普郡的劳拉·M.的一封信，她说，这不是一个问题，但安吉拉在
phone to her landlord. I heard it. Is it when I say in the end or something? Yeah, clearly on your end. On your end. Yeah. I have an audio clip. Oh gosh, I heard it. Is it when I say in the end or something? Yeah, clearly on your end. On your end, yeah. I have an audio clip. Oh gosh, I heard it too. This is Angela. Oh, hello, Ms. Plonkowski. How can I help you? Did my rent check not clear?
电话里对她的房东变得很有南方口音。我听到了。是不是当我说“in the end”（最后）什么的的时候？是的，很明显是在你那边（on your end）。在你那边。是的。我有一个音频剪辑。噢天哪，我听到了。是不是当我说“in the end”什么的的时候？是的，很明显是在你那边。在你那边，是的。我有一个音频剪辑。噢天哪，我也听到了。这是安吉拉。噢，你好，普伦科夫斯基女士。我能帮你什么忙吗？我的房租支票没有清算吗？
Because I just transferred another $25 to that account. So if there's a problem, it's clearly on your end. There it is. It's clearly on your end. It's not my problem. It's on you, lady. Well you guys know I go southern in three situations. One, hungry.
因为我刚刚又转了25美元到那个账户。所以如果有问题，那显然是在你那边。就是这样。这显然是在你那边。这不是我的问题。这怪你，女士。好吧，你们知道我在三种情况下会有南方口音。第一，饿了。
Two, annoyed. Three, a little tipsy. That's true. Well, Andy is still determined to, I guess, burn all his bridges. He's going to burst into the conference room and confess to David Wallace that he is the reason why they lost the White Pages account.
第二，生气了。第三，有点微醺。这倒也是。好吧，安迪依然决心要，我猜，破釜沉舟。他要冲进会议室，向大卫·华莱士坦白，他们之所以失去了白页账户，他就是原因。
And he might poop on Wallace's car. He really needs to get fired. And as he's leaving, he gives David Wallace two birds, two middle fingers. Yeah, shoots him the birds. I got the lowdown on standards and practices here. Here are their notes. They said this, quote, page 33, blur Andy's hand as he gives the finger gesture and then in parentheses they put, f*** you, to David Wallace.
而且他可能还会在华莱士的车上拉大便。他真的很想被解雇。当他离开时，他向大卫·华莱士竖了两个中指，两个中指。是的，朝他竖中指。我这里有关于审查和标准的内幕消息。以下是他们的笔记。他们这么说，引述如下，“第33页，当安迪做出竖中指的手势时，模糊安迪的手，然后在括号里写着，去你的，针对大卫·华莱士。”
In case you weren't sure what the gesture meant. Exactly. And then they wrote, page 35 and page 39, it is our understanding that Andy's squatting on the hood of Wallace's car, his pants around his ankles will play off camera. Well, standards and practices, your understanding was incorrect because when I watched the episode, it was not off-camera. It was full on-camera, but pixelated.
以防你不太确定这个手势是什么意思。没错。然后他们写道，“第35页和第39页，据我们理解，安迪蹲在华莱士的车前盖上，裤子褪到脚踝处的画面将在镜头外进行。”好吧，审查和标准，你们的理解是不正确的，因为当我观看这一集时，它并不是在镜头外。它是完全在镜头里的，只是打了马赛克。
So I'm not sure what happened when their understanding was not met, but those were their initial script notes. Well, now Andy's out in the parking lot. He's packing up his car, and Angela approaches. I love doing the scene with Ed. This was a beautiful scene. Yeah, this was our character's last big scene together. Wow. Yeah. Yeah. Well, you're so great in this scene. I really would love someone to write a series for you that is like this character. The one sipping on the big gulp at her wits end.
所以我不知道当他们的理解没有实现时发生了什么，但这些是他们最初的剧本笔记。好了，现在安迪在停车场了。他在收拾他的车，安吉拉走了过来。我很喜欢和埃德一起拍这场戏。这是一场美妙的戏。是的，这是我们两个角色之间的最后一场重头戏。哇。是的。是的。好吧，你在这场戏里演得太棒了。我真的很想有人为你写一部像这个角色这样的剧集。那个一边喝着大杯饮料、已经智穷才尽的角色。
Kind of, yeah. You're really great at it. Thanks. I think this could be a series. This character could have a journey, and I'd like to follow that thread with you in the lead. Well, it would certainly be a fun role. I agree. And I'd never have to worry about doing the back of my hair, ever. Oh, it would certainly be a fun role. I agree.
差不多吧。你真的很擅长这个。谢谢。我觉得这可以拍成一个系列。这个角色可以有一段心路历程，而我很乐意由你领衔，沿着这条线索演下去。嗯，那绝对是一个有趣的角色。我同意。而且我再也不用担心打理我脑勺后面的头发了，永远不用。噢，那绝对是一个有趣角色。我同意。
And I'd never have to worry about doing the back of my hair ever. Oh no, no, no, no. That character does not do the back of her hair. No. She aggressively does not do the back of her hair. Right, and the cowlick that I have would just be. It just works.
而且我再也不用担心打理我脑勺后面的头发了，永远不用。噢不，不，不，不。那个角色才不会打理她脑勺后面的头发呢。不会。她极其坚决地不打理脑勺后面的头发。对，我有的那个发旋就会。那就刚好。
It would just be an accent on the perfect hairdo. Exactly. I do want to point out one thing in the script. At the end of the scene between Angela and Andy, when Angela walks away would be the moment that Andy clocks David Wallace's car and makes the decision to poop on it. I see.
那只会成为完美发型的一个点缀。没错。我确实想指出剧本中的一件事。在安吉拉和安迪之间的戏结束时，当安吉拉走开时，正是安迪注意到大卫·华莱士的车并决定在上面拉大便的时刻。我明白了。
And so then when he walks into the bullpen with his guitar and says, no turning back, it's because he's already pooped on the car. Yep. Okay. Well, this next scene, I mean, if you wanted to make a lady sob at her desk at 2.30 in the afternoon on a Tuesday, congratulations,
所以当他拿着吉他走进办公区并说“没有回头路了”时，是因为他已经在车上拉过大便了。没错。好的。好吧，接下来这场戏，我的意思是，如果你想让一位女士在周二下午两点半坐在桌前痛哭流涕，恭喜你，
mission accomplished. I watched this, and I wasn't the same for the rest of the day. This is when Andy came in with his guitar, Lorelei. He wants to sing his goodbye. He's a performer and that's how he wants to say goodbye. Yeah, there was a fan question from Alexandra in Tasmania, Australia who said, I love the scene where Andy sings, I Will Remember You by Sarah McLachlan. And I think it's such a great choice for Andy to sing it in a normal singing voice and not his usual kind of a cappella
任务完成。我看了这个，接下来的一整天我都不太对劲。这就是安迪带着他的吉他进来的时候，罗蕾莱。他想唱一首他的告别曲。他是一名表演者，这就是他想要说再见的方式。是的，来自澳大利亚塔斯马尼亚的亚历山大有一个粉丝提问，她说，我很喜欢安迪唱萨拉·麦克拉克兰的《我将记住你》的那场戏。而且我认为安迪用平常的歌唱嗓音而不是他平常那种阿卡贝拉
theatrical singing voice? Was that scripted or did Ed Helms choose to sing that way? Well, Alexandra, it was scripted. It was scripted that the song is good and that everyone in the office is impressed. Steve Burgess said that that song cost $25,000 for us to be able to do. And I think that when I watched this scene, it brought back so many deep personal memories from shooting it. And I really was not the same the rest of the day. And then I dreamt about the show that night. I dreamt, does this ever happen to you?
戏剧性的歌唱嗓音来唱，真的是一个太棒的选择！那是剧本里写好的，还是埃德·海尔姆斯选择那样唱的？嗯，亚历山大，那是剧本里写好的。剧本里写了这首歌很好，而且办公室里的每个人都很印象深刻。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，为了让我们能够使用这首歌，花了两万五千美元。我想当我看到这场戏时，它勾起了许多拍摄时的深刻个人回忆。我真的在接下来的一整天里都不太对劲。然后那天晚上我梦到了这部剧。我梦见，这事在你身上发生过吗？
I have dreams where we're back on set and we're making more episodes dreams where we're back on set and we're making more episodes. Like we're making season 10. Yeah, yeah, I've had that similar dream that I am walking from hair and makeup to get mic'd. Yeah. To go onto stage and the stage is right there
我做过这样的梦，梦见我们回到了片场，正在拍摄更多的剧集，梦见我们回到了片场，正在拍摄更多的剧集。就像我们在拍第10季一样。对，对，我有过类似的梦，梦见我正从化妆间走去别麦克风。是的。去到舞台上，而舞台就在那里
and I'm looking at our desk and I'm about to walk into the bullpen and I'm getting mic'd and it's so real. So real. Watching this for this rewatch triggered that and I ended up having a dream. Also in my dream, we all pick up right where we left off. Yes, exactly.
我看着我们的办公桌，我正要走进办公区，我正在别麦克风，这一切是如此真实。如此真实。看这个重温引发了这一切，我最终做了一个梦。同样在我的梦里，我们所有人都在离开的地方无缝衔接。是的，完全是这样。
Like no one has to get reacquainted with their character or instantly those people again. Yeah, it's not like those anxiety dreams where like, oh no, I don't know my lines. It's always like this pleasurable, I'm getting emotional thinking about it. I'm gonna move to a fan question from Maddie R. in Kansas City who said, when Andy sings to the office,
就像没有人需要重新熟悉他们的角色，瞬间又变成了那些人。是的，这不像那些焦虑的梦，比如，噢不，我不知道我的台词了。它总是那种令人愉快的，我想着它就觉得情绪激动。我要转到一个来自堪萨斯城的球迷马蒂·R.的提问，她说，当安迪对着办公室唱歌时，
we see lots of emotional reactions from the staff. Were any of the emotions we see real reactions from the cast being sad about the show ending? Well, Maddie, we shot this at the end of the day on Friday. So the end of the day at the end of the week, it was the last group scene we shot for this episode, and it was deeply emotional. It was very emotional.
我们看到了员工们许多情绪化的反应。我们看到的任何情绪都是演员们对剧集即将结束感到难过的真实反应吗？嗯，马蒂，我们是在周五快下班时拍摄的。所以是在一周结束时的傍晚，这是我们为这一集拍摄的最后一个集体场景，而且情绪极其深厚。非常情绪化。
We just all knew that there was just a few more weeks left at this point. And Andy was really saying goodbye. This character is saying goodbye. And right before we did the scene, there were two camera setups. There was a master shot to get everyone. And then there was going to be a close-up of me and Rain as Dwight and Angela have their exchange. And Jeff came up to me and said, save it for your close-up. So feel the emotion, but really let it come through
我们当时都知道，这时候只剩下最后几个星期了。而安迪是真的在说再见。这个角色在说再见。就在我们拍摄这场戏之前，有两个机位设置。有一个拍摄所有人的主镜头。然后将会有一个我和雷恩的特写镜头，因为德怀特和安吉拉有他们的对手戏。杰夫走到我跟前对我说，把情绪留到你的特写镜头里。所以去感受这种情绪，但一定要让它通过
on your dialogue line. And sometimes that's hard to calibrate because you just start to feel it when you feel it. But I do remember this scene, I was so emotional. I don't know how many takes we did, but I had to hold that for the whole time. Wow. Yeah, you know, this was one of our last
你的台词表达出来。有时候这很难拿捏，因为当你感受到它时，你就会开始动情。但我确实记得这场戏，我情绪太激动了。我不知道我们拍了多少条，但我必须把那种情绪保持整个过程。哇。是的，你知道，这是我们最后的
kind of everybody bullpen scenes. Cause we knew that in the next episode, Andy was off pursuing his dream and we don't see him until like the very end. And so yeah it felt like, wow. It felt like people's story arcs were wrapping up. Yeah. And this scene was a very tangible moment of that. Yes. In this scene of all the emotion I do have one moment that I'm calling busted. What's that? At 15 minutes and 18 seconds,
那种全员办公区的场景之一。因为我们知道在下一集里，安迪去追求他的梦想了，我们直到最后才见到他。所以是的，感觉就像，哇。感觉就像人们的故事线都在收尾。是的。而这场戏正是对此非常切实的一个时刻。是的。在充满各种情绪的这场戏中，我确实发现了一个我称之为“抓包”的时刻。是什么？在15分18秒时，
as Clark comes out of the kitchen into the bullpen, you can see Clark Duke for one second, look right down the barrel of the camera. Oh really? Just for a second. And we weren't supposed to do that, you know, we were not supposed to look right into the camera unless we had a talking head.
当克拉克从厨房出来走进办公区时，你可以看到克拉克·杜克有一秒钟，直直地盯着摄像机的镜头。噢真的吗？就一秒钟。我们本不该那样做的，你知道的，除非我们有面对镜头的独白，否则我们不应该直视摄像机。
Or unless there was like a scripted note. Exactly, the way Jim would do that. Sure. Well, I had these guys pull an audio clip of the song, but I honestly don't even think I can listen to it. Oh, no, we need to. It's so emotional. I know, but we need to.
或者除非有什么剧本提示。没错，就像吉姆会做的那样。当然。好吧，我让这些家伙提取了这首歌的音频剪辑，但我老实说，我甚至觉得我没法听它。噢，不，我们需要听。这太情绪化了。我知道，但我们需要听。
We've all been on this rewatch together. Everyone listening is here with us. And we're going to have to say goodbye to the show again, Jenna. We are. I don't mean, now you're tearing up. I don't goodbye to the show again, Jenna, we are. I don't mean, now you're tearing up. I don't wanna make you sad, but we are going. We can listen to it.
我们一直在一起重温。所有收听的人都和我们在这里。我们又得和这部剧说再见了，珍娜。我们是的。我的意思是，你现在眼泪汪汪的。我不想——又得和这部剧说再见了，珍娜，我们是的。我不是指——你现在眼泪汪汪的。我不想让你难过，但我们确实要。我们可以听的。
Okay, okay, we'll listen to it. Let me get some tissues. Here it is. Tuna, I'm a performer and perform I Shall. ["I Shall"] I will remember you, will you remember me? Don't let your life pass you by And weep not for the memories Remember all the good times that we had Let them slip away from us when things got bad How clearly I first saw you smiling in the sun I wanna feel your warmth upon me
好吧，好吧，我们听一下。我去拿些纸巾。给你。金枪鱼，我是一个表演者，而表演我必将进行。["我必将"] 我会记住你，你会记住我吗？不要让你的生命从指缝溜走，也不要为回忆而哭泣。记住我们拥有的所有美好时光。当事情变糟时，别让它们从我们身边溜走。我最初看到你在阳光下微笑是多么清晰。我想感受到你带给我的温暖。
I wanna be the one Cause I will remember you You're okay It's just really nice of you I will remember you Will you remember me? Don't let your life pass you by And weep not for the memories. Don't let your life pass you by. And weep not for the memories. You know what it is? It's like I can't believe that we have a recording of like Ed singing
我想成为那个人 因为我会记住你 你没事吧 这只是你真的太好了 我会记住你 你会记住我吗？ 不要让你的生命从指缝溜走 也不要为回忆而哭泣。 不要让你的生命从指缝溜走。 也不要为回忆而哭泣。 你知道这是什么吗？这就像我简直不敢相信我们竟然有埃德唱歌的录音
to us, which is something that him and Creed and Craig and Kate, you know. They would do when they, we were just hanging out. Yeah. Yeah. And so that song brings up all the memories of us hanging out. And it's like, this is one of the crossover ones. This is like, it was for the show, but it was also for us. And it just hits deep.
唱给我们听，这是他和克里德、克雷格还有凯特，你知道的。当我们在闲晃时，他们就会这样做。是的。是的。所以那首歌勾起了我们一起闲晃的所有回忆。这就好像，这是那种跨界的歌曲之一。这就像，它是为了剧集而唱的，但也是为了我们自己而唱的，它直击心灵深处。
Yeah. And it makes me miss Ed. It makes me miss Ed. It makes me miss all of us in a room together like that. Yeah. Because it was so, so fun. And so special. Yeah. And I think, you know, Andy's going to have his line about how you wish you were in the good times, you know, whatever that line is, later.
是的。这让我想念埃德。这让我想念埃德。这让我想念我们所有人像那样聚在一个房间里。是的。因为它是如此、如此有趣，而且如此特别。是的。我想，你知道的，安迪后来会有一句台词，关于你多么希望身处美好时光中，你知道，无论那句台词是什么。
But we actually did know, we actually did realize. So I feel like we were really present to the specialness and also the limited time of this. Like we were aware it was coming to an end. So we were especially, it was heightened. Yeah. Well, you know, Phyllis and Stanley are gonna have a talking head.
但我们实际上确实知道了，我们实际上确实意识到了。所以我觉得我们真的很专注于这种特殊性，同时也意识到了时间的有限。就像我们知道它即将结束一样。所以我们特别地，这种情绪被放大了。是的。好吧，你知道，菲利斯和斯坦利会有一段面对镜头的独白。
They're facing out as well. Are they? Yup. They're gonna say maybe Andy can make it. Yeah. They were so impressed by his song. And Phyllis says, worse people make it all the time like Little Romeo. And Stanley is like, no, Little Romeo was good. I want you to know this scene was longer and the two of them debated musicians and artists for a bit. And it was so funny. It's not in deleted scenes, but it was in the shooting draft.
他们也会面向外面。是吗？对。他们会说也许安迪能成功。是的。他们对他的歌印象深刻。菲利斯说，更糟糕的人一直都在成功，比如小罗密欧。斯坦利则说，不，小罗密欧很不错。我想让你们知道，这场戏原本更长，他们两个对音乐家和艺术家争论了一会儿。而且非常搞笑。它不在删减片段里，但它在拍摄剧本里。
I love Phyllis's reaction to Stanley saying that Little Romeo was good because it's like she's going to bite her tongue. Like, I can't have this argument again. They've had it so many times. There's such a moment of assumed history between these two people in that moment. Well, I thought I was done crying as I was watching this episode, but no. Now we're going to go to Angela's desk,
我很喜欢菲利斯听到斯坦利说小罗密欧很不错时的反应，因为那感觉就像她咬住了舌头。就像，我不能再争论这个了。他们已经争论过好多次了。那一刻，这两个人之间有一种假定历史的厚重感。好吧，本以为我看这一集时已经哭完了，但并没有。现在我们要去安吉拉的桌子那儿，
and she's looking at tense on her computer. And Oscar's gonna approach her, realize that she's looking at tents on her computer and Oscar's gonna approach her, realize that she is looking at tents because she has nowhere else to be. What is wrong with me? And you know what? I'm gonna read these letters. Okay, we got a lot of letters about this scene
她在电脑上查看帐篷。奥斯卡走近她，意识到她在电脑上查看帐篷。奥斯卡走近她，意识到她正在查看帐篷，因为她无处可去了。我到底怎么了？你知道吗？我要读这些信。好吧，我们收到了很多关于这场戏的信
and they deserve to be read. Okay, here it is. Susan C. in Plano, Texas. I have been waiting to write to you since this podcast began over four years ago. Now's the time. I would like you to know that the scene between Angela and Oscar, when Oscar sees Angela in distress,
而且它们值得被阅读。好吧，给你。来自德州普兰诺的苏珊·C.写道：自从这个播客四年前多前开始以来，我一直等着给你写信。现在是时候了。我想让你知道，安吉拉和奥斯卡之间的那场戏，当奥斯卡看到安吉拉陷入困境，
offers her living space until she gets on her feet and reaches over to place a comforting hand over hers. Oh, my gosh. This is the embodiment to me of grace and mercy. And after all they have been through together, all the ways they have wounded or tried to kneecap each other, all the ways they have irritated
提供给她住处直到她重新振作起来，并伸出手把一只安慰的手放在她的手上时。噢，天哪。这对我来说就是优雅和仁慈的化身。在他们经历了这一切之后，经历了所有互相伤害或试图背后捅刀子的方式，经历了所有让他们彼此
the fool out of one another. Oscar compassionately reaches out to his friend in love and she responds not with pride or rebuff, but with tender acceptance. I love this moment in the series so very much and commend both Angela and Oscar for their acting. It could have been maudlin, but instead it is pure gold. And I couldn't have said it better, Susan, thank you.
烦得要命的方式。奥斯卡充满同情地向他的朋友伸出充满爱意的援手，而她的回应不是傲慢或拒绝，而是温柔的接受。我太爱剧集里的这个时刻了，并且称赞安吉拉和奥斯卡的演技。它本可能会流于矫情，但相反，它是纯金一般的品质。我再也说不出更好的了，苏珊，谢谢你。
And Angela, Christine C. from New York said, one of my all-time favorite scenes is when Oscar tells Angela to come live with him and Angela takes his hand saying thank you. I've watched the show over 100 times, no exaggeration, and this moment always moves me to tears. Angela, what was it like to approach this change in your character while also staying true to who she was?
还有安吉拉，来自纽约的克里斯蒂娜·C.说，我历来最喜欢的场景之一，就是奥斯卡让安吉拉去和他一起住，而安吉拉拉着他的手说谢谢。我看这部剧超过100遍了，绝无夸张，这个时刻总是让我感动得落泪。安吉拉，在保持角色本真的同时，又要演绎出角色身上这种转变，是一种什么样的体验？
Oh y'all are gonna make me cry. Um you know I approached it as oh gosh. Are we gonna make it to the finale? Angela we are a mess. We are a mess. Um you know to play these characters honestly they had to be real people to us. And Angela's best friend in the office was always Oscar. Even though we kind of like that sibling that you love but can get under your skin more than anyone else. That familiarity breeds contempt person in your life, but is the only person you probably really trust. Yeah.
噢，你们俩是要让我哭吗。嗯，我是以——噢天哪。我们能撑到大结局吗？安吉拉，我们成了一团糟。我们是一团糟。嗯，你知道，为了真实地演绎这些角色，他们对我们来说必须是真人。安吉拉在办公室里最好的朋友一直是奥斯卡。尽管我们有点像那种你爱但比任何人都更能惹恼你的兄弟姐妹。那种在你的生活中让你爱恨交加、却可能是你唯一真正信任的人。是的。
And that's how I played that relationship, even though we had big disagreements that he was my best friend. Yeah. And so when he was so gracious and kind to me in that moment, I feel like all this pride that Angela had held onto had broken apart. And that's why she had that conversation with Andy in the parking lot. She was like, don't
我是带着这种关系去表演的，尽管我们有过巨大的分歧，但他是我最好的朋友。是的。所以当他在那个时刻对我和蔼可亲时，我觉得安吉拉一直死死抱有的所有傲慢都土崩瓦解了。这就是为什么她在停车场和安迪有那样的对话。她当时说，别
let pride get in the way. Yeah. So thank you for noticing that in our performances. I'm really proud of that scene. And I'm really thankful I got to do it with Oscar, someone who I'd known for so long, and I trusted in real life so that I could go to that vulnerable place. But I want you guys to know one of the things I absolutely love when I rewatch this,
让傲慢挡了路。是的。所以谢谢你们在我们的表演中注意到这一点。我为那场戏感到非常自豪。我也非常感谢能和奥斯卡一起完成它，这是一个我认识了很久、在现实生活中我也信任的人，这样我才能进入那个脆弱的境界。但我希望你们知道，当我重温这一集时，我绝对最喜欢的事情之一，
I loved when I touched his hand. Same, that was what got me. Yeah, and I just said thank you to him from the bottom of my heart. Yep. But what I loved about doing scenes with Oscar is we could play this emotion and stay in it and then also find a comedic moment. When you ask him if his place allows pets. I improvised that line. Oh lady and his response. That was not scripted. The scene ended with, let's go get Philip
我喜欢当我触摸他的手的时候。一样，那就是戳中我的点。是的，我从心底对他说谢谢。没错。但我最喜欢和奥斯卡演对手戏的地方在于，我们可以把这种情绪发挥出来并沉浸其中，然后还能找到一个喜剧时刻。当你问他他的住处是否允许养宠物时。那是我即兴发挥的台词。噢，天哪，还有他的反应。那不是剧本里写的。这场戏本该在“我们去接菲利普
and we'll get your stuff. And I say, okay. That's where the scene ended. And then we were to get up and walk out. And Oscar and I had been in accounting for a long time. We knew if we made it quick, especially on an exit, an improvised line might make it in. So we didn't even talk about it.
然后去拿你的东西”这里结束。我说，好的。这场戏就是这样结束的。然后我们本该起身走开。我和奥斯卡在会计部待了很久。我们知道如果我们动作快点，特别是在退场时，一句即兴台词可能会被保留下来。所以我们甚至没有提前商量。
He said, let's get you the hell out of that place. And then there was this brief pause and I said, are you allowed to have pets? And he's like, oh, Angela. And it made it in and that delights me every time I see it. Well, it's so great because it helps you release some of your emotion with a laugh at the end. Yeah.
他说，让我们把你从那个鬼地方弄出去吧。然后有了一个短暂的停顿，我说，你们允许养宠物吗？他就像是，噢，安吉拉。这被剪进去了，每次我看到它都让我感到开心。好吧，这太棒了，因为它在最后用一个笑声帮你释放了一些情绪。是的。
Oh, I love that moment. I did not know that was impro end. Yeah. Oh, I love that moment. I did not know that was improvised. Yeah. Oh, so good. Dwight now has a talking head. He says, just yesterday he was a paper salesman with a farm and a dream about beet fuel, but today he's regional manager with the black belt.
噢，我太喜欢那个时刻了。我不知道那是即兴发挥。是的。噢，我太喜欢那个时刻了。我不知道那是即兴发挥。是的。噢，太棒了。德怀特现在有一段面对镜头的独白。他说，就在昨天，他还是个有着农场和甜菜燃料梦想的纸业推销员，但今天他成了拥有黑带的地区经理。
It's amazing how life can change in one day. I'd like to point out that his talking head is facing towards the bullpen. Because his future is at Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. I love that so much. Well, speaking about futures, Darryl is going to find Jim in the kitchen and share some happy news that Athlead received an offer for a buyout. And they want them to go on the road for three months.
生命能在一天之内发生如此巨大的变化，真是令人惊叹。我想指出的是，他的独白是朝着办公区方向的。因为他的未来在邓德米夫林。是的。我太喜欢这个了。好吧，说到未来，达瑞尔在厨房找到了吉姆，并分享了一个好消息，阿斯利德（Athlead）收到了收购要约。
They want them to pitch out west because they don't want this to be a regional thing. They want Athlead to be national. And Darrell's like, we're going on the road, buddy. We did it. He's so excited. But Jim says, I can't do it. I can't do it to Pam. And Darrell's like, can't do it. I can't do it to Pam.
他们想让他们上路出差三个月。他们想让他们去美国西部做推销，因为他们不想这只是一个区域性的业务。他们想把阿斯利德做成全国性的。达瑞尔就像是，我们要上路了，老伙计。我们做到了。他太兴奋了。但吉姆说，我做不到。我对 Pam 做不出这种事。达瑞尔就像是，做不到。我对 Pam 做不出这种事。
And Darrell's like, can't believe it. And they kind of walk out, and you see that Pam has overheard this from the bathroom. Which I think is so important. I'm so glad they had that moment. I am too. And I know where this is going, and I have a few gripes about it, but I'll bring them up next week when we get to them.
达瑞尔就像是，简直不敢相信。然后他们走了出去，你可以看到 Pam 在洗手间里听到了这一切。我认为这太重要了。我很高兴他们有这个时刻。我也是。我知道这会走向何方，对此我有一些微词，但等下周我们聊到时我会提出来的。
Okay. Hold it, hold it. I will. Now we have this scene of Angela and Oscar in Oscar's car, they're in the parking lot, and Angela starts it off kind of snarky. She's like, so is your place all bachelor, slobby and gross?
好的。等等，等等。我会的。现在我们看到安吉拉和奥斯卡在奥斯卡的汽车里的这场戏，他们在停车场，而安吉拉一开始有点尖酸刻薄。她就像是，那么你的地方完全是单身汉那种邋遢恶心的风格吗？
And Oscar's like, no, it's neat and tasteful. Yeah, so you said it really lives up to the gay stereotype. Yeah, and then Angela, the sass, still in her, even when she's at her broken lowest moment, she goes, I wouldn't know, I never lived with a gay guy. And Oscar's like, Angela, you were just. Yeah, he's like, you did. You did, and then she completely breaks down and starts sobbing.
奥斯卡就像是，不，干净且有品味。是的，所以你说这真的很符合男同性恋的刻板印象。是的，然后安吉拉，那种傲慢，即使在她彻底崩溃的人生低谷时刻依然留在她身上，她说，我可不知道，我从来没跟一个同性恋男人同居过。奥斯卡就像是，安吉拉，你刚刚——是的，他就像是，你住过。你住过，然后她彻底崩溃，开始痛哭流涕。
And she says, I love him. And Oscar thinks she's talking about the senator and she says, no, I love Dwight. Now Angela, I know you've shared this before in different places, but will you tell people how you got to this cry? There was this moment, a piece of direction from Jeff Blitz that really helped you here. Well, in the other scenes, my cry could build, but in this scene, they wanted me
她说，我爱他。而奥斯卡以为她在说参议员，她说，不，我爱德怀特。现在，安吉拉，我知道你以前在不同的场合分享过这个，但你能告诉大家你是怎么进入这种哭泣状态的吗？杰夫·布里茨给的一个导演指导时刻真的在这里帮了你。嗯，在其他的戏里，我的哭泣是可以层层递进的，但在这场戏里，他们希望我
to all of a sudden break down. They wanted just her to break apart. And that's harder to do. Yeah. Because emotionally you can, like when Andy was playing the guitar, there were so many moments I could run through my mind to be teary.
突然崩溃。他们只想要她整个人分崩离析。这更难做到。是的。因为在情感上你可以，就像安迪弹吉他时，我脑子里可以闪过很多时刻来变得动情。
But this had to be go from kind of being snarky to an instant breakdown. Yeah. So we did one take and I did break down. I kind of built up to it a little bit. And then Jeff came over to me and said, Angela, that was great. And now I have that. And he said, can you step out of the car for a second?
但这就必须从有点尖酸刻薄瞬间转变为彻底崩溃。是的。所以我们拍了一条，我确实崩溃了。我稍微做了一点铺垫。然后杰夫走过来对我说，安吉拉，那太棒了。现在我有这个了。他说，你能下车一下吗？
I want to talk to you. I said, OK. So Oscar stayed in the car. And he said, will you do a favor for me? And I said, yeah. And he said, oh, it's going to make me cry. It's good direction. He said, in this take, will you say goodbye to the show?
我想跟你谈谈。我说，好的。所以奥斯卡留在车里。他说，你能帮我个忙吗？我说，行。他说，噢，这要让我哭了。这是个很好的指导。他说，在这条里，你能向这部剧说再见吗？
And will you say goodbye to all the characters? And will you say goodbye to playing Angela Martin? So on your line, I love him, the subtext he wanted was goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye to these people I love. Mm-hmm. And this character. And so I was thinking about that even as I said my snarky lines. Mm-hmm. And so when I got to I Love Him, it was I'm never going to get to do this again. Yeah, this is it for me on the show. Nine years of my life I'm saying goodbye to. And I cried, big ugly cry. I cried so hard that after the take, Jeff came up to
你能向所有的角色说再见吗？你能向扮演安吉拉·马丁说再见吗？所以在你的台词中，我爱他，他想要的潜台词是再见。再见。向这些我爱的人说再见。嗯-hmm。还有这个角色。所以我甚至在说我那些尖酸刻薄的台词时都在想着这个。嗯-hmm。所以当我说到“我爱他”时，那种感觉就是我再也不能做这件事了。是的，这就是我在剧中的结局了。我要向我生命中的九年说再见了。我哭了，哭得极其难看。我哭得太厉害了，以至于拍完后，杰夫走到
me and said, that was fantastic. I can't use it. It's too much. That's what happened to me when Paul Feig told me to say goodbye to Steve at the airport. Oh my gosh. He was like, that was great. And he said, I don't want to say too much. He said, I want you to stay in it. Can you do that just a little less? And you guys, some people, I guess they can cry and look attractive, not me.
我跟前说，那太棒了。我不能用。这过头了。保罗·菲格在机场叫我和史蒂夫说再见时，我就是这样的。噢，天哪。他当时说，那太棒了。然后他说，我不想说太多。他说，我想让你保持那种情绪。你能稍微少一点点吗？你们大家，有些人，我猜他们哭起来可以很好看，我不行。
When I cry, it is like a full body wheezing. I can't talk. But what you see is real tears and it's me saying goodbye to the show in that moment. And I wanted to share one thing that just delighted me. I found an article that the AV Club did about this episode. It was written by Joshua Alston and he was very excited to finally get to review an episode of season nine in particular because he was a big fan of season nine. And the first one he was assigned to do was Living the Dream. And it wasn't his favorite. Oh no. But he wrote this, I can't help but wonder if I'd have the same impression of living the dream if I hadn't read that it was originally planned as a half hour installment, then padded out to fill an hour. But I suspect I would.
当我哭的时候，就像是全身都在喘粗气。我连话都说不出来。但你看到的是真情实感的眼泪，那一刻的我就是在向这部剧说再见。我想分享一件事，这让我感到非常高兴。我发现了一篇 AV Club（影音俱乐部）关于这一集的文章。那是约书亚·阿尔斯顿写的，他非常高兴能终于有机会评论第9集的一集，特别是他作为第9集的超级粉丝。而他被分到的第一篇评论就是《活出梦想》。这不是他最喜欢的一集。噢不。但他写了这样的话：“我不禁在想，如果我没有读到它最初计划作为半小时的一集，然后被拉长填充成一小时的话，我对《活出梦想》的印象会不会有所不同。但我猜我会的。”
I hope this gets better. And he goes on to point out some of the things he liked about it, but that it had just kind of been stretched out maybe more than it needed to be. Listen, I felt that. Yes, than it needed to be. Listen, I felt that. Yes. I felt that. But I also know that the things that hit in this episode,
我希望这一集能变得更好。他接着指出了一些他喜欢的地方，但它确实被拉长了，可能比需要的时间更长。听着，我有同感。是的，比需要的还要长。听着，我有同感。是的。我有同感。但我也知道，这一集里那些戳人的点，
they couldn't have been done in 22 minutes. So sorry if you had to sit through a couple of repetitive beats, but it's what needed to be. Yes. And then at the end of his review, he said this, I didn't talk about the Angela story because I didn't want to go into too much detail. But her life sucks now that she's left the state senator.
是不可能在22分钟内完成的。所以很抱歉，如果你不得不忍受几个重复的节奏，但这正是所需要的。是的。然后在他的评论结尾，他说过这样的话：“我没有谈论安吉拉的故事，因为我不想陷入太多细节。但自从她离开州参议员后，她的生活一团糟。
Her cats were seized, she got evicted from her apartment, and is apparently a double-digit bank transfer away from indigence. I'd love for Dwight and Angela to end up together, but I wish the writers had chosen a path that didn't involve Angela being reduced to nothing first. That said, an uptight gay Mexican sharing an apartment with a differently uptight school marm whose ex-husband is his former lover? The words, the office spinoff, usually make me break out, but in all caps, that is a show I would watch.
她的猫被没收了，她被公寓驱逐了，显然离赤贫只有十几笔银行转账的距离。我很希望德怀特和安吉拉最终能走到一起，但我希望编剧们选择一条不用先把安吉拉贬得一无所有的路。话虽如此，一个死板的同性恋墨西哥人，和一个同样死板、前夫是自己前男友的女教师合租一套公寓？这些词，办公室衍生剧，通常让我起鸡皮疙瘩，但大写加粗地说，那绝对是一部我会看的剧。
Yeah. I always felt that way too. I was like, Angela and Oscar sharing in an apartment, sign me up. It's like the odd couple. I wish we could see more of that. Yeah. Well, I'll have you know that critically, this episode was very well received. And in fact, these last six episodes, Live in the Dream Part 1, Live in the Dream Part 2, AARM Part
是的。我一直也是这么觉得的。我想，安吉拉和奥斯卡合租公寓，算我一个。这就像是一对冤家。我希望我们能看到更多这样的情节。是的。好吧，我要告诉你的是，从评论来看，这一集非常受欢迎。事实上，最后这六集，也就是《实现梦想（上）》、《实现梦想（下）》、《A.A.R.M.（上）》
1, AARM Part 2, Finale 1 and 2, this block of six episodes were rated the highest among OfficeTally.com viewers as well. There is this stretch here where we got people excited. Like the critics and fans alike, they liked where this was going. Well, by this time we're also invested in these characters and big life stuff starts happening. Well, that's the end of this episode. Thank you Steve Burgess for all of your behind the scenes tidbits. And thank you all for writing in. And Angela, thank you for your nifty gifties. You're welcome.
《A.A.R.M.（下）》以及《大结局（上和下）》，这六集在 OfficeTally.com 网站的观众中评分也是最高的。在这个阶段，我们让大家兴奋起来了。就像评论家和粉丝一样，他们喜欢这样发展的方向。好吧，到这个时候，我们也对这些角色投入了感情，重大的人生事件开始发生。好吧，这一集就到这里。感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯分享的所有幕后花絮。谢谢大家写信来。安吉拉，谢谢你送的精美小礼物。不客气。
And thank you Mary. Beatrice. Davidson Kenner. Yes, for inventing the toilet paper roll hook and sanitary napkin. When she did the sanitary belt specifically, she did it with her sister, Mildred Davidson Austin Smith. So it was two sisters. Two sisters helping ladies out.
还要谢谢玛丽·比阿特丽斯·戴维森·肯纳。是的，感谢她发明了卫生纸卷钩和卫生巾。当她专门发明卫生带时，她是和她的姐姐米尔德里德·戴维森·奥斯汀·史密斯一起完成的。所以是两个姐妹。两个姐妹在帮助女性。
I mean, amazing. Amazing. Well, there you go. That's helping ladies out. I mean amazing. Amazing. Well, there you go. That's living the dream part too everybody. Thank you for listening. We love doing this and we hope you have a great day. We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
我的意思是，太棒了。太棒了。好吧，就是这样。这就是在帮助女性。我的意思是太棒了。太棒了。好吧，就是这样。各位，这就是《实现梦想（下）》。谢谢大家的收听。我们热爱做这件事，希望你们今天过得愉快。我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubberree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》是 Odyssey 的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制片人是艾因斯利·巴巴科。Odyssey 的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯·伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴塞尔进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubberree》。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。